hey anthony cause i'm the only one
single when
you are doing your budget what category
would you put
dating expenses and paying for dating
apps
i actually want to know the answer to
this james i'm really looking forward to
this
or would you make that his own separate
category also
ao because i'm the only one single how
much money
would you put in it should it be a
percent
of your income or just an overall dollar
amount now before you answer this i've
never looked forward to an answer
as much as i'm looking forward to this
answer to the blinds.com
question of the day take it away come
this is the best one in the fight
everybody's
been on this team this is the best one
and by the way single people all over
the world in america they're
listening and they're going talk to me
hey man listen man but you know the
reason why i'm laughing is because in
the single world when you mention you're
on a budget that's actually a turn off
it is actually a turn off to single
ladies like oh you're a jeep
no ain't g i just have a clear budget
for what we're doing so yeah i love it
when you are dating you should have a
line item on
your um your budget uh that says
dating um and and you know there's
different kind of things out there
dating can mean multiple ladies or
multiple guys
uh but dating just simply hey for this
month i'm going to spend x amount of
dollars on on
going out on a date and so for me as a
single person who is
dating um i do have a line item it's not
really a percentage
um it's not really a certain amount once
i cover my four walls
okay once i cover my utilities my
housing my transportation and my food
and my mandatory bills and then if i had
that as long as i am eliminating my uh
debt then i'll set aside whatever you
feel comfortable
uh setting aside so if that's 50 for the
month great if that's 150
for the month great um i wouldn't
definitely do a large amount and a large
percentage
i would just definitely sit back and say
you know what hey you know i'm gonna go
out on a couple of dates this this uh
this month
um with my young lady who i am dating or
my young man who i'm dating
and um we're gonna go to the movies and
go out to you know get a nice little
meal cool great
put that on a separate line item and
that and for me it's up underneath my
leisure category so like just spinning
stuff now these dating apps i mean
come over to my show i'll talk to you
about the dating apps i don't really
feel comfortable talking about
dating apps on the ramsay show oh very
well very oh look at that was very
political
you might as well be running for
congress nobody because i can go a
little bit deeper on the table with
anthony o'neil right
but i mean right anything around dating
yes you do want to have a line item
make sure you cover your priorities and
uh make sure that it is not a lot
but make sure it is comfortable to where
you can't enjoy yourself you know what
occurs to me
uh is uh you know james kelly we're
married right so dates with my wife
it's it's a little different than when
you're single so ao i'm wondering
uh if this in when you're single in the
single game are you spending more
on those initial dates uh or do you
spend less and eventually ratchet it up
versus like date night for us
to take stacey out to dinner and and
it's just nice to get away from the kids
i mean we're at that stage where it's
like just a nice dinner
uh three hours of conversation with no
kids is
fabulous when you've been you know
married as long as i have and have kids
you know you know i was slammed last
year because i did a video and i said my
first date on anyone who i go out with i
will not spend no more than fifty
dollars
this is what i was wondering i like this
you're kind of going we're prospecting
right now i'm not gonna invest a lot
here yeah i'm not i mean i
like this i don't want to sit here and
spend 150 on a woman that i may not even
see or want to be and you know slammed
oh yeah
as in what you're cheap oh yeah because
ladies like 50 dollars i mean
i can't even get a steak for 50 well
first off you're not gonna get a steak
with me on our first date
you know i mean i've been able to this
is fantastic
my savings account looks looks good now
because i've been a good
steward of my money what does the lady
get on a first date with you
oh man what's what she's going to get
she's going to get my heart she's going
to get intentionality
she's going to get creativity so we're
gonna go to the park
chicken and a salad the kids menu no
dessert
i'm just saying like she's gonna see
okay he put thought behind this date
we're gonna go to a museum we're gonna
go walk in the park i'm gonna
you know maybe cook something from the
house and bring it on a little picnic
and then we sit down and
you know we watch the stars she's going
to see creativity and then once again
tupperware apparently
absolutely you know i have no shame in
my game all right
this is good stuff here uh i think it's
good you're taking a stand
young man out there you don't have to
blow the budget on the first date is the
takeaway that's my takeaway
and uh this is a good point here if you
want to go deeper
with ao on stuff like this and he does
and it's fabulously entertaining
the table with anthony o'neil now is
available as a podcast it's already
wildly popular on youtube
just search the table with anthony
o'neil and then again it's wherever you
listen to podcasts
and man he's going into this and all
kinds of stuff and let me tell you about
my man
he brings it oh yeah there's no filter
oh yeah so there you go go check that